[Musica]
eccomi qua
questo sono io nel mio habitat naturale
tra le montagne però vi voglio
raccontare un pochettino come ho
iniziato andare in montagna perché tutto
non è stato così semplice
quando mio papà mi portava una ventina
d'anni fa avevo 13 14 anni e all'inizio
nemmeno mi piaceva andare in montagna e
addirittura io mi ricordo una delle
prime volte che sono andato a scalare a
metà parete mi era venuto da piangere mi
sudavano le mani non mi sentivo portato
per questo sport
e poi ho deciso comunque di riprovare di
andare ancora arrampicare perchè per me
scalare da un po un limite volevo vedere
se ero capace di superare questo limite
di migliorare in questa attività è così
dando un po una seconda chance alla
montagna o pian piano sono migliorato ho
iniziato a sentire il mio corpo in
maniera diversa e ho scoperto anche una
grande passione perché proprio iniziato
a piacermi con l'europa insieme abbiamo
scalato su tantissime vie delle alpi
prima era lui che mi portava poi
andavamo a comando alternato poi ero io
che portavo lui
insomma abbiamo costruito un percorso
bellissimo e addirittura questa passione
poi è stata così forte che ho scelto di
dedicarmi proprio come lavoro dedicare
tutta la mia vita alla montagna
addirittura ho lasciato diciamo una
carriera da ingegnere per fare
l'alpinista come professionista e
parlando di alpinismo
diciamo che per noi alpini sti quelli
che sono i confini in realtà li
intendiamo come delle sfide verso
l'impossibile cioè agli alpinisti da
decenni praticamente provano a spostare
pil il limite di ciò che viene ritenuto
fattibile
ciò che per una generazione viene
ritenuto impossibile poi viene scalato e
quindi per la generazione successiva
diventa quasi normale un punto di
partenza verso nuove montagne perché
anche quando tutte le montagne del mondo
sono state scalate
gli alpinisti si inventeranno sempre
comunque nuovi problemi da risolvere vie
nuove da aprire da salire in diversi
stili
nel 2006 ho avuto la fortuna di entrare
a far parte dei ragni di lecco che sono
un gruppo mitico che non ha
bisogno di tante presentazioni del quale
però hanno fatto parte voglio solo
citare alcuni nomi alpinisti come
bonatti cassin carlo mauri persone che
sono stati in grado di sfidare
l'impossibile spostare in live meeting
in anni in cui veramente il mondo era
completamente diverso da quello di oggi
e entrando a far parte dei ragni di
lecco
ho iniziato anche io stesso ad avere
l'opportunità di girare il mondo e
insomma provare a scalare qualche
montagna che non aveva mai scalato
nessuno per me le montagne che più mi
affascinano sono le montagne della
patagonia i ragni di lecco hanno una
storia gloriosa in patagonia perché le
loro salite sono sono state e mitiche
come le salite del sero torre del fitz
roy la patagonia si trova in sudamerica
e al confine tra argentina e cile
queste montagne diciamo perché mi
piacciono mi piacciono perché al di là
della bellezza estetica che mi attira
questi pinnacoli di roccia che escono
dal ghiacciaio perché nella patagonia tu
senti gli elementi vivi senti la natura
proprio su di te quando il tempo è
brutto c'è un vento che di spazza via
senti proprio la forza degli elementi e
confrontarmi un po con queste montagne
qualcosa che trovo molto molto
stimolante per me il mio sogno adesso è
legato diciamo all'attraversamento di un
confine a una sfida che nessuno è mai
riuscito a portare a termine è legato ad
aprire una nuova via sulla parete est
del sero torre in stile alpino
il senatore forse la montagna più famosa
della patagonia e queste sono un po le
sue dimensioni quindi una montagna
enorme con dove gli scalatori sono solo
delle formichine in inermi che si
arrampicano sulle sue pareti
ho avuto la fortuna già di scalarlo due
volte nel corso degli anni la prima per
la via che va aperto cesare maestri nel
1970 la famosa via del compressore dove
il compressore usato per piantare chiodi
ancora presenti in parete
e la seconda per la via che avevano
aperto i ragni di lecco nel 1974 una via
di ghiaccio che sale dal versante ovest
ecco però provare ad aprire una via
nuova in stile alpino sulla parete est è
qualcosa di completamente diverso è un
gioco che richiede delle capacità
totalmente differenti perché se per
salire da delle vie esistenti comunque
avendolo già fatto qualcuno tu puoi
avere delle informazioni
sai che comunque una cosa possibile
perché di fatto fai delle ripetizioni
quando apre una via nuova e soprattutto
su una parete così grande ti metti in
gioco ti confronti con l'ignoto e non
sai se mai riuscirà effettivamente a
portare a termine questa sfida è un
gioco che richiede tantissime capacità
ovviamente richiede un sacco di
preparazione un sacco di allenamento e
poi richiede coraggio perché senza
coraggio in alpinismo non si va da
nessuna parte ma richiede anche è la
capacità di somma di saper rinunciare di
valutare la situazione perché non è che
si scherza quando si fanno queste
scalate e quindi ci sono da valutare un
sacco di fattori e parlando sempre di
patagonia
la mia prima spedizione in patagonia
quella che mi ha fatto innamorare di
queste terre è stata per aprire una via
sulla sorella minore del senatore che la
torre egger quella che si trova proprio
di fianco anche qui eravamo solamente in
due e siamo partiti per confrontarci con
con l'ignoto con una parete dove non
c'era nessuna via e saremmo dovuti
essere i primi a doverla scalare è stata
una spedizione dove per riuscire nel
nostro intento
ci sono volute un sacco di di giornate
addirittura parliamo di mesi e siamo
dovuti tornare in patagonia tre volte
per riuscirci e dove sono molto legato
al punto di vista affettivo per via di
tutte le emozioni condivise con il mio
compagno di cordata eravamo ero con
matteo bernasconi altro mio collega dei
ragni di lecco ed insieme abbiamo
passato un
sacco di momenti di gioia di difficoltà
di attese e in questa spedizione voglio
raccontarvi brevemente quello che è
stato il momento più difficile perché è
stato un momento molto emblematico per
la mia carriera di alpinista e per la
mia vita è stato quando il secondo anno
di tentativi sembrava che stessimo per
arrivare in cima a questa montagna
e invece proprio quando i giochi
sembravano fatti sembra che ce la
stavamo per fare io cerco di salire mi
attacco a questo chiodo convinto che
stesse andando tutto bene lavoro testate
teneva e poi pam in un momento del tutto
inaspettato quando povero me l'aspettavo
il chiodo è uscito sono uscite le altre
protezioni che avevamo e siamo rimasti
tutti e due appesi a un solo friends un
friends è una cosa è questo praticamente
eravamo in due appesi a un aggeggio del
genere con mille metri di vuoto sotto
ovviamente per quell'anno la spedizione
è finita lì perché perché nessuno se la
sentiva di di tornare su questa parete e
questa cosa però mi ha dato tantissimo
da riflettere perché noi alpinisti
quando decidiamo di provare a scalare le
pareti
dobbiamo sempre tenere in conto che
comunque la linea è molto sottile si
gioca con quello che è il bene più
prezioso che abbiamo ovvero le nostre
vite no e quindi mi sono chiesto se
veramente valesse la pena
il fatto di mettere una posta in gioco
così alta per quello che volevamo fare
perché è innegabile che con tutta la
preparazione che puoi avere comunque dei
rischi li devi correre la mia risposta è
stata che comunque per me scalare queste
montagne ormai rappresenta la mia vita è
una passione talmente forte da farmi
sentire realizzato in quello che faccio
che ero disposto ad accettare questi
rischi anche quando vedevo e sentivo
tanti amici che purtroppo in montagna
non ce l'avevano fatta e non sono più
con noi
e sempre parlando di alpinismo alla cosa
che però mi affascina
di più di questa disciplina è la
creatività la libertà che noi alpinisti
abbiamo perché gli alpinisti non abbiamo
un campo di gioco con delle regole
definite dove dobbiamo giocare appunto
come come in tutti gli altri sport ma
possiamo scegliere noi cosa andare a
fare quello che più ci ispira per
esempio qualche anno fa ci è venuta
l'idea a me a due miei amici di fare
questa spedizione dove già solo
l'avvicinamento comprendeva 200 km con i
kayak e poi fatti questi 200 chilometri
una bella parete da scalare di 900 metri
anche questa mai scalata a cui seguiva
ovviamente il rientro via mare con i
kayak e questa spedizione è stata
importantissima per me perché
rappresenta un po quello che è il mio
stile di andare in montagna dove quello
che cerco è un confronto ad armi pari
tra l'alpinista l'uomo e la natura che è
di fronte dove si vuole limitare al
massimo la tecnologia per permettere un
confronto il più puro e autentico
possibile e questo invece è il cerro
torre
la montagna di cui vi ho parlato prima
la montagna a cui dove sicuramente
tornerò perché questa montagna occupa
costantemente i miei pensieri
per me il limite
il fatto di attraversare un confine
adesso è riuscire ad aprire una via
nuova su questa montagna ma la cosa che
più conta per me è mettermi in gioco
essere disposto a tutto
prendermi i rischi avere il coraggio di
prendere certe decisioni ma ricordare
sempre che comunque bisogna essere
disposti in alpinismo ad ascoltare
quello che i dentro ad ascoltare le tue
paure come diceva anche il grande
riccardo cassin
la paura è l'anticamera della prudenza
quindi uno deve ascoltare quello che ha
dentro e deve essere anche disposto a
rinunciare nel caso in cui le cose non
andassero come come vuoi perché la
rinuncia
tu la vedi come se tu sei disposto ad
accettarla non è altro che una nuova
opportunità di rimetterti in gioco e di
riprovare una seconda volta a
raggiungere questo tuo sogno
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]